want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you two you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
amazing motivation from the one and only
jay shetty enjoy
the first thing i'd say is i think
everyone needs
the feeling that they can just come up
for some air
life can often feel like someone's
literally
drowning you and you feel like you're
drowning and floundering especially if
you're in an extreme case of anxiety or
stress or depression
and i feel like you just need to feel
like you can just come up for a tiny bit
of air so for that in the book i talk
about the 3s model which is your sights
sense and sounds
what we see
what we hear and what we smell has a
profound impact on our mental state and
we actually underestimates our sense and
i'll give you an example all of us been
walking around with masks and someone
said this to me the other day and it hit
me
they were saying to me that now that we
all wear moss and do this the whole time
i think my mom's over there they were
doing this all the time they realized
they couldn't hear people properly
and the reason they couldn't hear people
properly is they realize they don't use
their ears they use their eyes to see
people's lips
and so actually they're not even using
their ears that much they're using their
eyes to follow the lips and know what
someone's saying
so actually we depend so much on our
eyes
in every interaction
how many times you've been looking at
someone attractive and you forgot what
they were talking about
right you're just so engaged with your
eyes that you completely even forgot to
listen
right or you're so lost in in the vision
of something again and you're in a daze
you can't smell anything you can't taste
anything
so
we've got to learn to reactivate our
senses so i'll give an example of what i
mean as monks
our life was sight designed
designed and scent designed
what's the first thing you see when you
wake up in the morning for eighty
percent of people the first thing they
see in the morning is their phone and
the last thing they see at night is
their phone
that is poor sight design because you
don't even choose what the first message
of the day your mind receives that
actually made my stomach drop
that's that's a gnarly thought it's true
yeah right imagine the last thing
someone sees is not their partner or
their spouse the person they sleep with
they see their phone and the first thing
in the morning they look at is their
phone and guess what it's not a good
site but you're looking at a message
that you didn't design for your mind
you're looking at a picture or an image
that maybe came through on your
instagram feed that you didn't choose
for your mind so now you've started your
day with envy jealousy comparison
competition collab like all of the all
of the monkey mind stuff and the monkey
mind's excited the monkey mind is on the
monkey mindset yeah we're ready to go
and now you started the day with the
monkey mind so my advice is
start your day with a quote that you
love
start your day with a picture of someone
that you love or your family start your
day with a work of art that inspires you
start your day with seeing the first
thing that you see make it so closely
connected to your soul and your goal and
your purpose
that your monk mind naturally comes
alive
so as monks the first thing that we saw
was sometimes a teaching that would keep
next to us it might be a spiritual text
where i just ripped it out of a book and
stuck it there next to my bed so i woke
up to there
just wake up to something that you
actually want to see when you wake up
and make it intentional and make it
focus it could even be a reminder on a
sticky note i remember for a long time i
had one when i was a monk that said i am
not this body
just to disconnect from the fact that i
was more than this body
and because we didn't have mirrors in
the ashram it was very easy to forget i
was this body
or i've had other ones where that say to
me i'm exactly where i need to be and
i've read that in the morning
and that just reminds me because so
often i wake up feeling anxious that i'm
behind on my day or i'm late and then i
actually make up a mess whereas if i
read i'm exactly where i need to be and
i remind myself i can start my day there
so that's sight
this and that's simple easy for anyone
to do you don't have to change your mind
you don't need to meditate you have to
do anything the second one is let's talk
about scent design now one of the things
i've been missing during quarantine is
going to a spa
or going to like a resort because i love
massages and i love spas and like me and
my wife love getting away
and if you think about it whenever you
go into a spa or a massage space or
whatever they're called or a resort
you can always feel relaxed from the
moment you walk in just through the
power of scent
it could be the most basic room in the
world
but a scent can literally illuminate a
whole room
so sense like eucalyptus lavender
sandalwood if you've got a diffuser or a
candle and you can make this a part of
your routine before you start your work
day just have a candle that you breathe
in for four seconds and breathe out for
four seconds
have a diffuser in your room that just
makes you feel calm because as soon as
you walk in one thing i've been doing is
putting eucalyptus drops into my showers
and turning into a natural steam and i
just feel like completely relieving all
my sinuses and and feeling calm these
are just really practical things you can
do to just ease yourself into it and the
third one's sound this one's so powerful
sound is underestimated because now we
just have
music playing all the time in the
background and the music may not even be
intentional and the lyrics are all over
the place and
you've got instruments that are not
being played well or in harmony and you
get a pump or like a
boost out of it and i've i learned about
sound in the ashram and we had sound
design we would wake up to nature sounds
and nature's so aligned with your body
and mind if you look at nature if you
breathe in with the ocean
your breath will just be exactly where
it needs to be
if you
allow yourself to just be present with
the wind you'll feel your body just slow
right down and be calm nature just has
this amazing way of teaching so many
lessons
and so when i lived in new york city i
often found myself getting exhausted and
i started looking into it i was thinking
what is it i work out i do all this
stuff and i realized that especially in
new york we deal with a lot of
insignificant sound you know something
called cognitive load where your brain
is processing
irrelevant in significant sound of
trucks
horns
construction work and drilling and so
when your ears are trying to make sense
of insignificant sound you're losing
energy in an irrelevant way
and so sound design means every room in
your home
have a song that plays or music that
plays in that room that gives you the
feeling you want it to have
another easy way to do that is before
you start work or while you're working
have a song or a playlist that really
gets you into the mode that you want to
be in when you're doing that
sound is a beautiful accomplice to any
activity you want so those are three
simple ways that anyone starting today
can bring the ashram to their home by
sight scent and sound design i've always
had a rule since i started that all my
videos are 70 complete so that's my rule
yes it's 70 that's all you're getting
yeah there's words that i say wrong
there's fumbles there may be a few
mistakes here and there the editing may
be slight but it's like my rule was 70
because that journey from 70 or 75 to 99
could take
decades yeah you can never it could i
would never release something and i
remember in 2016 after my first ever
video one of my first videos that went
viral
i actually got so scared because it was
almost like oh i have to live up to that
now so i remember not creating yeah and
so i went from creating one video a week
to create one video a month and guess
what i learned less
i was engaging less to connect with my
audience to understand what they needed
and what i was giving yeah and i was
trying less ideas yeah which meant that
i wasn't learning you weren't learning
as much i wasn't growing at all i wasn't
progressing and the world was being
taken from getting more beauty from
which came from a place of not thinking
like that which came from a place of not
trying to be perfect exactly the
original video that did well came from a
genuine place of just wanting to serve
and trying to figure it out and then all
of a sudden we're not serving anymore
and so i was like okay this doesn't make
any sense and i was like actually and
then last year when we started making
more videos i can honestly handle my
heart say that when we started doing
three videos a week i started to learn
so much more yeah i was like oh i really
like it when i write like this and i
really like it when i create like this
and the audience really responds when i
share it this way and i was learning so
much more yeah and i was feeling more
fulfilled by making more mistakes but
learning more and so my mistakes
increased yeah but your learning
increases
which which was a much more
fulfilling place to be even though it
was tough at times but it was fulfilling
so every morning
i sit and i look at my intentions to do
anything so whether there's a new deal
on the table or there's a speaking gig
that i've invited to do or whatever it
may be and in your life it could be
anything whether you're starting a new
business you're writing a book it may
even just be an instagram post for
whatever it is and i look at whatever my
options are
and i ask myself which ones of these is
a seed and which ones of these is a weed
because the incredible thing in our
garden is that weeds end up looking like
seeds and can confuse you 100 so so
often that thing that's giving you ego
and pride and fame and control and power
looks like it's amazing right but
actually it's just strangling you 100 so
so every day what i'll do is i'll look
at the garden of my life and i will try
and
unweed my garden so i'll look at
everyone be like why am i doing that and
ask me that why am i doing that if the
answer is not love compassion empathy
growth right personal push sacrifice
service if the answer is the opposite
greed money power fame if those are my
reasons then i have to take that weed
out hundred percent i have to pull it
out because if i don't pull it out that
weed's gonna keep growing right and one
day it's gonna be so big
right that i wouldn't have never seen it
i think the first thing is you've got to
get comfortable being you
see no one will ever be comfortable with
you being you if you're not comfortable
being you and i think we first try and
prove ourselves to other people so my
favorite this is like i talk about this
all the time it's it's probably one of
my favorite pieces of insights it's from
a
writer named cooley in the 1900s and he
said today i'm not what i think i am i'm
not where you think i am i am what i
think you think i am
so what he means by that is
we are living in a perception of a
perception of ourself
if i think you guys think that i'm nice
then i feel nice if i think that you
think i'm weird i feel weird so we're
constantly living through the perception
of a perception of someone else
so my first thing is get away from that
take that away figure out how you feel
about yourself so i'll say happiness is
how you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself
right like how do you feel about
yourself when you're by yourself when no
one else is around there's different
ways to play the game
some people spin the ball some people go
for a straight direct role some people
use two or three things the list
continues the truth is it's exactly the
same in our lives
you will see some people succeeding in a
certain way and others doing it
completely differently the goal is to
find your way your method your approach
the direction that works for you without
trying to copy or mimic or imitate
someone else
and we've all experienced this
sometimes your ball
ends up
in the gutter i'm sure you've had that
before sometimes your throw was
completely out of control and your ball
went directly into the gutter
or maybe sometimes you actually felt
well prepared and confident but the ball
still ended up in the gutter in life
just like that ball sometimes we feel
we're in the gutter but there's
something to learn from that and just
like the ball comes back
when we learn through our experience
we get another opportunity to improve
another opportunity to try another
opportunity to succeed as oscar wilde
said
all of us are in the gutter but some of
us are looking up at the stars sometimes
you hit a spare
you threw your best shot you got the
angle perfectly right you prepared with
everything you had
and that one pin
is still
up there
sometimes despite our best efforts in
life
we don't get what we want
not everything aligns everything doesn't
go to plan
life is a lot like bowling keep your
eyes on the ball your concentration in
the game
and your mind out of the gutter
and in the end we realize we have to be
just like that bowling pin no matter how
hard we're hit by life no matter how
hard we're hit by others
we have to keep
stepping back
up that has happened so many times when
a video you think is gonna hit
and it doesn't and then there's a video
you're like that's never gonna hit and
it does
and
that's where i've reconciled myself down
is recognizing that i don't always know
what's going to work
and that's a beautiful thing
and that i've been and i and i've been
feeling this often that
i've got to where i want in life just
not in the way i imagined it
and that's the beauty of
giving up that control
and feeling slightly liberated so i'll
give an example of what i mean by that
i'm always working strategically
effectively and impactfully in the best
ways i can but sometimes the place where
i put my most energy does the worst and
sometimes something that i tried on the
side like blows up and it's incredible
and that's where i've reconciled myself
down recognizing if i'm putting my best
foot forward and i'm working
strategically and effectively the things
that are going to work will work and it
may not be the things i expect and what
we're doing is or what i do sometimes
too is you're so focused on wanting one
thing to work you miss the fact that
there's like nine other things that are
happening that are amazing around you
that you could never have dreamed of and
i've seen that in my life countless
times where i wanted one thing to work
three things were working over here but
i was so like why is this not working
like why is this not working that you
missed that so self-doubt for me is
something that i've tried to build a
close relationship with and i get it all
the time i still get it before a post
before a video before anything i mean i
was just in you know i'm working on my
book right now i just launched a podcast
and before i launched the podcast i had
no idea
how well it was going to do how badly it
was going to do or anything and there
was a part of me that was like are
people going to listen to this like are
people going to care like i ask myself
all those questions still today
number one i'm glad i asked myself those
questions it means i'm human it means
that i care
it means that it's important to me
i speak at so many conferences and
everyone always asks me do you still get
nervous i go yes i get nervous because i
care the day i stop feeling nervous that
means i don't care anymore if i don't
care anymore that means i don't love
what i do anymore so for me the first
thing is i recognize that self-doubt
just shows me that i care and that
something's important to me whereas i
don't doubt myself around things that i
don't care about like if you ask me a
question right now about what's the
recipe for this amazing dish i wouldn't
know and i'd say i don't know and i'd be
okay with it because i don't care about
cooking i'm not a cook right but if it's
something that you care about you'll
have self-doubt the second thing that i
do with self-doubt is i go okay if
that's the things that i'm doubting
myself for
what strategies what can i put into
place to overcome them doubt is just a
great way of making you check
what you need to work on so if my doubt
is oh my god not enough people are going
to listen to this so i'm like okay so
how do we make it more listenable how do
we make the content better how do we
make the conversation better if my doubt
is
um you know i don't feel like people are
gonna like this topic okay what themes
am i good at talking about what is you
know it's it's a great checking system
to improve what you have so don't look
at self-doubt as negative
turn it into a positive by actually
asking yourself those questions right so
build a relationship with self-doubt
because it's never going to go away
right don't avoid it don't avoid it
definitely don't avoid it it's never
going to go away so if it's never going
to go away build a happy positive
relationship with it so my positive
relationship with it is you're showing
me
what i need to focus on to feel less of
that and most of us feel self-doubt
because we're not researching we're not
building knowledge we're not building
expertise and i think that's the biggest
thing for me is when i feel self-doubt
it's because i don't i'll give a perfect
example
when i was
thinking about doing a podcast and
you're doing interviews
you don't just become an interviewer you
have to watch interviews you have to
absorb good interviewers you've you
can't just be an interviewee you have to
watch good interviewees and so for me
a lot of us start something and we feel
self-doubt because we've never learned
that skill or we've never observed that
skill
so my focus is if i want to be a good
interviewer i need to watch good
interviewers if you want to be a good
stage performer watch good stage
performers if you want to be a good monk
watch good monks right you don't become
something good without seeing it
so
self-doubt comes because you haven't
upskilled and the great thing today is
you can do an online course you can
upscale from here you can obscure from
there you can just listen to this
podcast and watch you guys who've done
it for such a long period of time that's
a seeing someone who's done something
consistently
that's the best way of getting good at
something and then your self-doubt will
disappear so self-doubt can only be cut
by the sword of knowledge it can only be
cut by the sword of upskilling so that's
where it starts our identity should
start with unlearning
everything that we think we know about
ourselves okay how do we unlearn so the
best method of unlearning is this first
and i'm gonna get really strategic and
tactical because i think that people
need to know what to do rather than a
concept the first thing you do is write
down everything you currently are
chasing in your life make a lot of goals
your dreams your goals your dreams
published anything that you're currently
chasing and pursuing okay write them
down you can write down three equal
random five you can write down 10
depending on how ambitious you are
second line ask yourself what is the
source of that where did you get that
idea did you get that idea from
a tv show you saw did you get that idea
from your parents did you get that idea
from your mom and your dad your sister
your cousin did you get that idea
because your friend just got proposed to
on instagram did you get that idea
because your friend just got promoted
did you get that idea because
you just broke up right or did you get
the idea because you just feel it when
you do it that you feel alive just give
me a specific example that you had when
you were 15 18 was like a goal or
accomplishment that you were chasing and
where it came from absolutely so my my
goal when i was young was to be an
investment banker
and when i really asked myself where did
that come from it came because in my
community small community in london the
most successful person financially was
an investment banker so i believed you
had to be an investment banker to be
successful right so when i asked myself
that question where does that come from
it comes from society's version of
success not mine and then the third
thing you ask yourself is well then what
is mine what is coming from inside of me
and if you just do that three-step
process now what you're doing is you're
filtering out the noise and you're
starting to listen to your voice the
thing is you've got a voice inside of
you but it's quiet it's like it's like
jay like take note of me like lewis you
know and it's just like trying to get
through and the noise of everyone else's
opinions are so loud so this way you
filter it there's a thought that i love
which says you know who you are when no
one's watching
like what you do when no one's watching
that's who you are yeah
so
we all know when we're alone whether we
choose meditation or netflix like we
know when we're alone whether we choose
for a lot of people out there whether
they choose reading books and learning
or pornography right you know when
you're alone what you choose yeah
and and i think that that really helps
you overcome your ego
because when we reflect on ourselves
when no one's around
that's when we're truly uncovering who
we are one of one of the points and i'm
getting to the ego point but and i loved
what you just said now that if you sat
here and said i have no ego you can't
say that and i agree with the same for
myself if i sat here and said i had no
ego that would be a complete lie
and there's a beautiful story of
benjamin franklin that he had his uh 13
precepts before he died he had 13
qualities that he wanted to attain in
life before he passed away they included
things like integrity simplicity honesty
virtue etc so these were his 13 set and
at the end of his life he was asked
which one did you not attain and he said
the 13th one and they said what was that
and he said humility
and and that for me almost means that he
conquered it because you know he was
able to accept that he didn't conquer
you almost like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was like this is
amazing you know and it's true story 13
precepts are great read the book it's
there benjamin franklin's book and so
the reason why i'm sharing that story is
because
the way
you
overcome your ego
is to recognize that you're simply a
channel or an instrument
when you recognize that you're an
instrument and whether you believe in
the universe whether you believe in
power whether you just believe in
mentorship
you recognize that everything you're
giving is because someone's given to you
and someone's given to that person and
therefore you're becoming a vessel an
instrument a vehicle for the greatest
powers in the world and just being a
channel for that
and that allows you to feel two things
one thing is you feel liberated because
now it's no longer your burden it's not
like oh my god i've got to be the most
amazing person in the world it's not
like oh my god it's all on me
you're actually like wow actually yeah i
learned from that did you and that
teacher and that teacher and that
teacher now i'm just a vessel for
everything that i've gained and i'm able
to channel channel it and transfer it to
others so it liberates you from the
pressure and the burden of like oh my
god like everyone's expecting me to give
the best talk of my life like you know
but when you realize that you're not
you're just a channel and you're just
a transfer mechanism
and and the second part of the second
thing that it does is that it allows you
whenever your ego gets in the way and
says yeah we're doing well like i did
that i did that you start recognizing
and you get perspective and gratitude on
the fact that no actually i'm gonna pass
this
whatever good's happening in my life
pass it to my teachers pass it to the
people that shared it with me because
there is no one who is self-made we talk
about self-made millionaires there is no
one that word shouldn't even exist yeah
because no one none of us are self-made
i'm not self-made you want like and
that's not that's not a it's a cool term
though it's a cool term but it's
definitely not true yeah and it's not
true and it's not a dis like i'm not i'm
not criticizing this is not like a slide
dig at anyone of course for using the
terminology at all all i'm saying is
just that if we all truly reflect
and we don't i don't want the anyone
watching to think i have to be self-made
because if you have to be self-made then
you're going to have to self-fall too
yeah right and everything will be
self-self self and you'll fall on your
own and you'll rise on your own the
story is acclaimed to alexander the
great
it could be anyone and i would if if
that's not true then i would just listen
in and think of any great warrior or any
great emperor or someone who achieved a
lot in life and so the story is of when
he's on his deathbed
and when he's on his deathbed it's said
that he had three wishes
and those three wishes when his
ministers asked him what he wanted was
that he wanted
him to be carried by all the doctors
to his funeral so he wanted his coffin
and his body inside the coffin to be
carried by all the doctors the best
doctors to his funeral the second thing
is he wanted that path to be laid with
everything that he'd gained in life all
the jewels all the riches all the money
everything and the third thing he wanted
was that he wanted his coffin to be left
open so that you could see his hands on
either side
right and the ministers looked him and
said that is the most morbid thing in
the world like this is your last wish
and those are your three wishes and they
said why are they your three wishes and
alexander the great explained he said
that i want the best doctors in the
world to carry my body
because i want the world to see
that even the best doctors in the world
can't save you from death he said i want
the path to my funeral to be laid with
everything i've gained to show people
that you can't take anything with you
and he said i want my hands to be
outside of the coffin to show that we
come into this world empty-handed
and we leave this world empty-handed
and that's one of my favorite stories
and what i try and imbibe in my videos
and live by is that i believe that we
all have a finite number of breaths
and we all get an opportunity to make
them count
and there's a beautiful thought by maya
angelou where she said people will
forget what you did people will forget
what you said but people will never
forget how you made them feel
and for me that's what we've got all of
us have this
limited amount of time
and all that's going to be remembered is
how we made people feel and so for me my
videos are all about how am i making
people feel if i can give people a feel
of self-worth a sense of personal growth
a sense of confidence a sense of
self-esteem whatever it may be i want to
use my living time doing that how do you
deal with it when the doubt is coming
from the people that you really love and
you know they care about you
yeah it was hard i didn't go to my
graduate i graduated but never went to
my graduation ceremony so my mom doesn't
have a picture of me
holding my degree and that was a big
thing for her because i moved to india i
just went so i never went to that and
that was a big thing for her and
actually my parents i'm very grateful my
mom and dad are actually fairly liberal
and supportive of anything i've decided
to do it's my extended family that's had
more opinions and been more involved and
kind of stirring stuff up with my
parents if that makes sense so the way i
dealt with it was always asking myself
these questions around you know
is someone invested in my future
is someone going to be there for me when
i'm struggling and is someone paying my
bills like those are my three checking
system of who matters in life like your
soul your mind and your paycheck
and i think the biggest thing i asked
myself was just
am i going to look back on if i don't do
this am i going to look back going back
to the alexander the great story
am i going to look back on my deathbed
and say
my mom and dad held me back
because i may say i'm going to do it for
them i'm not going to do this decision
because i respect them and love them but
am i going to hate them in the end or be
bitter towards them or feel a negative
feeling towards them because i feel they
held me back
and if that's the truth i never want to
feel that about my parents they're
incredible
so i need to go and take the
responsibility to make this shift
and i think the truth is that
when we think people are holding us back
it's just us not taking responsibility
for us to push forward like that's all
it is because the truth is if you really
really really really really want
something right like if someone told you
right now you had to get on a plane and
there's a million dollars in new york no
one would say oh my parents can't afford
a place like no one would say that you
would do it if you really wanted it
you'd get on a plane right now and you'd
go pick that million dollars up so it's
our own insecurity that we reflect onto
the people around us and i think it's
really important i get it there are
people who are toxic around us i get it
i had that too there were people who
were just like
literally people said to me like you
realize you're gonna fail at being a
monk you realize when you come back no
one's gonna hire you you realize when
you come back no one's going to want to
be with you you really you know there
are so many things like people like you
know you're going to be socially dead
like no one's going to care where you
are there was so much of that
but it didn't get amplified because i
was strong in my conviction so the way i
dealt with it was just keep
strengthening your conviction rather
than trying to weaken the argument
because the the the opinions of others
will get weakened when you strengthen
your own right that's how it works you
don't weaken someone else's to
strengthen your own we're so used to in
our life having instant judgment
defining a moment and giving it a label
good or bad in the moment and i thought
how do i present a concept to the world
where we can laugh at ourselves and
realize that sometimes our instant
judgment or our instant labeling
processor isn't always correct yes how
do we how do we get that so this script
or narrative that i shared in this video
is on a gentleman who goes to buy these
cookies because he feels like having a
few cookies because his flight's delayed
and he sits down to eat these cookies
and the gentleman opposite him where
you're sitting right now starts to take
cookies out as well
and he's saying how's this guy and the
guy looks a little rugged he looks a
little scruffy he doesn't look put
together
so naturally all of our biases our
unconscious biases start coming up and
stemming up and we start thinking oh he
looks a little shady or maybe he doesn't
have money that's why he's taking my
cookies and we have this impression of i
me and mine these are my cookies how can
he take them
only to realize when he leaves that your
cookie box was in your bag
and that gentleman was sharing his
cookies with you
and then this person has this epiphany
of this moment of realizing how quick he
was to judge but how wrong he was and i
think all of us in different ways have
different moments in our life where
whether we misjudged a person the first
time we met them or we misjudged someone
because of the first thing they said to
us or we had a friend that now is our
best friend but our first impression was
oh they're a loser and all of a sudden
now we think they're amazing we've all
had the story and i'm just sharing it
again to give context we've all had the
story of the two wolves or the two dogs
however you want to phrase them if you
haven't i'll tell it now it's it's a
story of how inside of us there are two
dogs two wolves and they're fighting for
supremacy so inside you
one is the initiator and one is the
responder
your whole life you've been feeding and
listening to the initiator so your
initiating wolf is strong
powerful
bulky aggressive because it's been fed
well your whole life
and your responsive dog your responsive
wolf has not been fed has not been
listened to
and so it's weak
and feeble and meek and humble and
doesn't even stand to fight so when they
too come to fight inside of you this
this wolf's just gonna eat that wolf
right up and that's what's happening
right now so for all of us whatever two
wolves you're seeing whether it's your
mind and your intelligence whether it's
your intuition versus what your parents
say whether it's
expectations of society versus your
expectations of yourself like whatever
two wolves you have inside of you the
one that wins is the one you feed and
the ones you have been feeding
now if you're at a point where you are
and where i am and where all of us are
in different scenarios of our life we're
trying to shift and start feeding the
other one
it's hard because the other one's just
been fed more it's stronger it's able to
push you
it's able to dictate you
and this is where detachment's so key
that detachment doesn't mean that you
owe nothing detachment means that
nothing owns you
and most of us have become owned
by our darker wolves most of us have
become owned by the self that we don't
want so so that conditioning has been
drawn up the only way to break it is to
disrupt the pattern to really break that
it has to be and this is why i talk to
people about immersive experiences like
you meditate for 10 minutes a day on a
headspace that's wonderful and i
recommend it but that's not going to
shift this in a drastic way
you are going to have to go and spend a
week out in joshua tree with this shaman
you are going to have to take a break
islam jerusalem right we were both in
love with jerusalem like instead of
going on a holiday this year you are
going to have to go on a three-day
intensive transformative retreat and the
reason why i'm saying all these
different things is they all have
different budgets they're all available
in different countries you don't have to
go to india and live with monks
but you have to do something and it has
to be immersive because when you get
immersed in something then you're giving
something the power to break your
pattern
and i think the challenge is we're
trying to solve it by a little thing
every day which is a good start to get
us going but if you're really serious
about a massive shift in your life
wherever you're seeing that energy
coming from for the right side the
responsive side yeah you need to go
water that you need to go feed it you
need and you need to go give it energy
and that's what i think
we find that
and that's why i think people struggle
they still want to go on their beach
holiday
they they're like no i can't give that
up i need that or this weekend i still
need to go and do up my house and it's
like well no like just imagine what
would happen if this weekend you just
went on a three-day retreat that changed
your life like imagine if you just gave
that energy in terms of finding your
purpose that seems like it's the first
step is getting comfortable with
yourself understanding that how do we
take that next step towards finding that
purpose yeah so for me i i define it as
your passion is for you your purpose is
for others so your purpose is when you
use your passion to serve others that's
the the link so for me the focus
actually first becomes what's your
passion like what are you passionate
about what do you enjoy doing and then
the mis the parts that that's usually
miss everyone here is follow your
passion find your passion it's like a
cliche it's everywhere the difference is
get really good at it
like get so good at it and everyone
always misses that point you can be as
passionate as you want about tennis
but if you're not really good at tennis
no one's gonna care
and no one's gonna take no and i think
that's often missed that not only do you
need to find what you're passionate
about you need to turn it into an
expertise
which is undeniable and that requires
the hard work that requires the work
ethic that requires the early mornings
that requires the training in whatever
field you want to be
and then
and that's going to make you successful
so when you figure out your passion and
you get really good at it you're going
to become successful but you're only
going to be happy when you use that
success to help other people and then
you've got to figure out that link to
purpose so you're going to find your
purpose so when you realize hey i'm
really good at this i love it i get a
lot of happiness from doing it when you
start using that to make a difference in
other people's lives in any way it
automatically switches into a purpose so
you don't need to find your purpose it's
just an automatic evolution
of finding your passion and being really
good at it and that's where we're
messing up that we haven't found
something we love and we haven't found
something that we love that we've got
really good at so what we usually do
with our lives is we do things that
we're not good at and don't love right
or we do things that we're good at but
don't love and we need to switch into
the spaces of things that we love but
are not good at and get really good at
them and start finding out things that
you are good at and you do love i was
really shy i didn't enjoy stages i
didn't enjoy speaking my parents forced
me to go to public speaking and drama
school so i spent 14 to 18 in public
speaking drama school changed my life i
did not know what i wanted to speak
about so even when i finished at 18 i
still didn't like going on stage because
i didn't have anything to talk about so
now you've got the tools but you haven't
got the passion so i developed somewhat
of an expertise in four years but i
didn't have what i was passionate about
and when i became a monk
i was like this is it this is why i went
to public speaking school because i love
talking about philosophy i love talking
about science i love talking about
culture i love talking about
life i love talking about growth etc the
mind so i got what i was passionate
about when i became a monk
so for me the process came from four
years
of consistent public speaking school
like it changed my life and and that's
all thanks to my parents for forcing me
to go i had no interest in being a
public speaker or a storyteller any of
these things that was just i lucked out
and then it was me finding what i was
passionate to speak about and then i've
spoken i've spoken for three hours a day
for the last 13 years
and i spoke to audiences of xero
all the way to audiences now of
thousands but when i first started
speaking i remember i was invited to
speak at a university where i wasn't
getting paid for i was like 20 years old
i was invited to speak to this
university no one showed up
twice so they organized two events for
me i was meant to speak about life
philosophy et cetera all the kind of
stuff i speak about now and zero people
turned up and i practiced my speech both
times to an empty room as if it was a
packed room because i was like i'm still
going to practice and so for me having
done this for three hours a day for the
last 13 years
that's
now being
gratefully received online so i'm very
fortunate that it's shifted from an
offline world to an online world which
we can dive into but the point is it's
it's been my absorption and addiction
for like feet for over a decade now what
is the power of service and how can we
without going to an ashram how can we
take our strengths and really give them
purpose and meaning
yeah so
one of the biggest things with service
in the ashram is service is a part of
your daily routine so there is no choice
about whether you serve or not
so that's a really great way to live
because you're almost exposed to lots of
different types of service so some of
that would be cooking
for the homeless or underprivileged
children who don't have access to warm
meals some of it would be building
sustainable villages inside which people
can live and villagers can find a home
and an economy so you're always
connected to doing something for others
but here if i was going to ask a monk
why are we doing this what would they
say
they would say because i believe that
you have to see how you can be useful to
others so the dalai lama probably puts
the best that
really we're born to help others and if
we can't help them at least don't hurt
them
and to me that really sums it up
that we're born to help others we're
born with different gifts with different
geniuses with different talents to
improve the lives of others
and the question i always get from
someone in the audience who wants to ask
me an awkward question will be and
there's always one right and so the
person will say well jay how does
someone who has nothing in india or
africa do this like someone in in like a
really slum situation or a village
situation and they're always they'll
always pick on india and africa i'm not
saying those and i'll be like no but
this isn't for them i'm speaking to an
audience
that has
an education that has resources that has
network like i'm speaking to people who
can make a difference so anyone who is
in that area of society
has a responsibility so
anything that you're given in life
you're seen as a caretaker of
and the way you take the best care of it
is that you use it in the service of
others and that purifies you from
becoming attached to it and it feeling
like it actually eats you alive
and feeds your ego
as opposed to you now being purified and
cleansed of wealth success fame status
or time or whatever you have an energy
and you're now using it for the highest
cause so that's what they would say they
would say it's the highest cause of
using what i've been given in the
service of others whatever you've been
given see when you let go of the past
your pastor will let go of you and
that's harder to do like it's easy to
say it's hard to do the way to stop
living in the past is start living in
the now so start making plans right now
start making plans for the future start
spending time with people who also don't
get nostalgic i remember at one point in
my life i kind of detached from a lot of
people who spent a lot of time in the
past now they weren't negative people
they always talked about how things used
to be great in the old days you know
nostalgia that oh i felt so good a few
years ago that's what that was the best
years of my life i started to disconnect
from that because i realized that i
didn't want to be living feeling like
the best years of my life were going to
be at university and end there the best
years of my life or as a teenager and
end there i always want every year to be
the best year of my life right i never
wanted to settle or limit myself for the
feeling that the best years of my life
have already passed so sometimes it's
not even negativity it's just not
allowing us to move forward don't miss
an opportunity
to tell someone how much they mean to
you i just don't and i said it better
than that somewhere i can't find it
right now but i mean that like just
don't miss an opportunity like i was
saying that with my mentor i always told
him i loved him
always
and now that i can't tell him anymore
i'm just glad i did tell him it's like
ready yeah totally so like don't ever
leave someone
with about don't ever leave someone
without telling them how much they mean
to you because you don't know when
they'll leave
and and so like that is just like never
let your last interaction with someone
you know you're a bad woman or a bad one
yeah yeah express love or just
generosity exactly especially the people
you love right like you may have bad
interactions with people you once or
twice or a business but the people that
are close to you and you love the people
you'll regret it with don't just don't
it's just not worth living with one of
the biggest mistakes we make is that we
confuse
inexperience
with being unqualified
so because we've not tried a lot of
things we just naturally believe that we
can't be that good at them so if i've
never spoken on a stage i just think oh
i'm probably not good at that or if i've
never played golf i'd probably think i'm
probably not good at that and so we
start writing off things without even
trying them so the best method i can
share with someone is take the next
month
take the next four weekends in the month
that gives you eight days
and get really tactical every single day
that's why you're playing tennis a lot
right now yeah
take the eight days go join a course an
online course or workshop go shadow a
friend go to a seminar a conference go
to reading a book listen to podcasts go
and expose yourself to eight different
things in a month eight different things
eight different things in a month and
guess what in a month you will have
learned what you probably would have
learned in eight years because most of
us test one new thing a year maybe maybe
if that exactly right like some people
don't even do that but if you do eight
different things in a month and this is
how you have to see it if you went to
eight different restaurants in a month
you ask yourself after you eat a meal
like i had that burrito or i had that
taco did i like it right the first
question you asked yourself is did i
gotta try it first you gotta try it
first you gotta go to the restaurant
yeah there's no point so you're gonna
say did i like it
the second question you ask yourself is
why did i or why did i not like it
like why is so important i think too
many people just go i like it or i don't
like it why didn't i like and the third
question you have to ask yourself really
really simple is do i want to do it
again
and if you do
that's where you start uncovering is so
my point is inexperience do not
misinterpret inexperience for a lack of
qualification in the hope for money in
the hope for success we end up chasing
the wrong things and we make a mess we
end up with less than we started with
end up with more issues than we
bargained for whilst climbing that
ladder and that stairway we forget why
we started climbing in the first place
once the king of bhutan was asked by an
interviewer what the gdp of bhutan was
he was surprised and shocked he replied
by saying in bhutan we don't just
measure the gdp
we measure the gnh instead of just
measuring the gross domestic product
we measure gross national happiness in
the process of getting older we forget
the real goal of life
if you could make a little less and
spend more time doing what you love
would that make you happier
don't trade your happiness for what you
think you need
things can never make us happy because
they're temporary and limited
but experiences can last forever too
many people are working hard on things
they don't love to spend money they
don't have to buy things they don't need
to impress people they don't like
when we create our identity or on what
we do a career a job an occupation we
can never be happy because we're basing
it on something external but when we
create an identity around who we are and
what we want to be and become
then anything is possible and remember
we become successful by what we get
but we become happy
by what we give
don't get the two confused i start off
the chapter with this beautiful thought
from charles horton cooley and i love
telling it because it's just it's just
the best and i think it was written in
like the 1900s and he said today the
challenge is i'm not what i think i am
i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am it's
crazy man and it's like it blows my mind
every time i say it gives me the chills
like i feel it and the reason why i
start with identity is because i think
that's the root of all our challenges
and the first step to thinking like a
monk is starting at the root not
starting at the symptoms or the
superficial or the surface level but
let's go to the root
if you're playing a role if you're
wearing a mask
if you're
dressed in clothes that are not yours
then you end up living a life that's not
yours and in the book i give this
example of method acting yes
yeah amazing i'm a massive movie
junkie and i love method actors so
people like heath ledger of course from
the dark knight series you've got jared
leto so jared leto when he played the
joker in this is not in the book in
suicide squad he used to send dead rats
in the mail to his co-stars
he did because he was trying to get into
the mindset of how someone that
perverted would behave
and then daniel day-lewis when he was
filming for gangs of new york he's
actually wearing these coats that are
centuries old so that he can get into
character when he's off
yeah when he can feel it right he's not
wearing watches he's not carrying around
his mobile phone they're speaking in the
accents and he talks about how he
actually went crazy because guess what
when you fake being someone for so long
you think it's your reality
and that's what happens to all of us we
play a role at work we play a role at
home we play a role with our family we
play a role at our friends and then we
think that role is us right and we lose
ourselves and to me that is the core
reason why we're chasing things that are
not important to us the envy actually
is more of a
expression of how we feel about
ourselves rather than how we're
perceiving someone else it's actually so
much more about how comfortable we feel
with who we are how confident who we
feel with who we are how much
self-esteem we have how much
self-assurance we have enemy is more a
root of that than it is of the fact that
someone else is doing well it's less
about the fact that someone out there is
amazing making waves doing something
that you want to be doing it's more
about how we feel about ourselves and
it's experienced
in that way of looking at someone else
and reflecting back on us social circles
family circles someone else has done
amazingly in the exam someone just
landed a new job someone else just got
promoted and everyone's looking at you
going what are you doing right what have
you achieved where where are you today
where have you got right what's
happening with you tell us about you
and you're thinking you know you're
going through all your head you're
trying to come up with all the things
that you've thought about all the things
that you've achieved all the things that
you've done and you're trying to bring
it up like constantly but you're
struggling you find it hard because
you're now measuring your growth based
on someone else's you're now measuring
your success based on someone else's and
that is the
biggest challenge with envy that one of
the biggest challenges it brings in our
life is that it forces us to start
measuring our sex
sorry our success in comparison to
someone else's that is the biggest
challenge with envy
when we start comparing the level of our
success with someone else's you're
already on the wrong foot i think any
sort of
dress or any sort of
whether it be yeah a dress or appearance
or any of that if it's taking you away
from who you actually are and how you
like expressing yourself then then that
kind of contradicts
being able to be authentic and being
real so i feel more authentic wearing
this than i did wearing my robes when i
was a monk literally use your weekends
and evenings to do a test on anything
the best way is go into a course test it
out try doing it once go and shadow
someone who does it someone in your life
that does it if you want to be a
podcaster come and shadow you guys for a
week right and see what that life's like
see what it actually looks like to
research to sit with a guest to find new
guests to work it out like go and shadow
someone who's already doing it and then
try and do it for a day like try and do
the schedule of someone you look up to
for a day like if you can do that for a
day and you loved it then do it for one
more day and if you loved it do it for
another day and that's gonna trickle in
so that's a much smarter way to finding
your passion rather than just sitting
there and reflecting which is cool which
is important but i'd encourage you to
just get out there right get out there
and live the life of someone who's doing
it when they started that's another
point don't focus on what people are
doing now focus on what they were doing
when they started so a lot of people ask
me they're like jay how many videos do
you make a week i'm like i make three
videos a week plus my podcast on top of
that plus instagram and they'll say oh
wow that's too much and i was like yeah
but when i started i made one video a
week
right like you don't have to start at
what i'm doing now like you you start so
that you know go back to that right love
is a doing word it's active it's a verb
and if love is a verb then service is
the action and that's why love and
service
have to be so intertwined because i feel
that today when we talk about love the
definition is so skewed
when people hear the word love that's
what the problem is that's what the
problem is that's why i prefer service
to love
because service is the activation of
love
when someone loves someone they serve
that's
how love works and i think that's why
when we talk about love i agree
it's just because of phonetics
definitions
breaking it down
love has become so
badly abused like the word love is so
abused and misused in our lives it
really is right you say i love you to
people you don't love people use it to
manipulate people
we just throw love around right and as
much as it should be everywhere
it's also sacred
love's also sacred and that's why you
were able to experience it because it
was experienced through a sacred
mechanism you were able to experience
love yeah and i and i've never felt it
like that before because it also was
this sense of self-love as well yeah and
that's what you felt in jerusalem too
when you went and that's what i felt
and that's what i feel that we
experience love when it's through
service and engagement in that
atmosphere we don't just experience it
every single day i personally also
having become a i feel like i've become
even more of a seeker since being
involved
and that's opened me up to alternative
ideas alternative ways of thinking
learning from all different traditions
wherever i can and and i think that's a
really important part i think the
challenge with being a
immature seeker in my definition of it
is you find something it sounds cool and
you go that's it there's nothing else
and then a real seeker goes well that is
it but how can everything else even
enhance this and make this even greater
for me if this is where my faith is or
this is where my belief system is so i'm
someone who genuinely loves learning
from
people from all different walks of life
and backgrounds because i feel
if i was presented with a deeper more
meaningful philosophy and life structure
i would adopt it that's why because i'm
open to that we were left on the streets
for 30 days to fend for ourselves and to
figure it out just that's it you've got
your clothes that you're wearing there's
no money no food no shelter no nothing
figure it out
and
day one i'm like okay like you know
maybe it's a joke like maybe maybe
they're gonna come back at night and be
like no guys you know so i'm trying to
figure out what it is this is training
mode
and it's really interesting what what
your mind
there you go how cool is that that's
fantastic
[Music]
amazing that was incredible
that was so good i would so do that
again
that was incredible oh my gosh thank you
man
thank you
that was amazing
it worked out it worked out
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated you have a 35 chance of
actually following through that's what
the science says and that is not good
enough believe nation we need to do
better when you actually get motivated
and then create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do this
week you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you publicly commit to
somebody else like leaving a comment
below on this video it jumps even higher
so i want that for you i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week so i can celebrate with you
when i was 22 i decided to turn down my
corporate job offers and go and live as
a monk in india for three years and half
our days were silenced and half of it
was service so we meditated for half the
day and the other half we were trying to
serve humanity and make a difference in
the world wow so that is why you decided
to not just be in india and be a monk
you decided it's better to be able to
share this knowledge yeah well when i
left and came back i was in debt i moved
in with my parents age 26 and i was
trying to figure things out but a lot of
my friends now work at large
organizations and they were going
through stress and burnout and pressure
and so they started to invite me to
speak at their companies about
everything i'd learned as a monk and i
started to do that and i started to see
impact inside these organizations but i
really felt i was like
this knowledge and wisdom needs to reach
everyone in the world it needs to reach
further than just corporate boardrooms
so in 2016 only three years ago i
started making these videos which were
these wisdom bites
and thankfully to all of you and many
others who've watched them they started
to spread and ariana huffington was
someone who really supported them and
gave me an early tipping point too if
you want some amazing motivation from
brendan burchard check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there ambition
ambition but too many of us back away
from it because it got made bad right i
was scared to have ambition because you
know what if you have ambition too big
for your britches